good morning John last night as we must
do in this day and age I was googling I
don't even remember what I was searching
for but as you I'm sure know Google
nowadays actually attempts to guess what
you want to know before you finish
telling it what you want to know because
apparently we're so lazy that we'd
rather not move our fingers anymore than
necessary
it's a clever little trick and I imagine
that it works basically by figuring out
what other people have searched for
let's start with the same letters is
what you're searching for which is I
guess convenient ish more than the value
is convenient I think that the real
value is its ability to help us peer
into the soul of mankind so let's say we
start out with is lots of Google queries
must begin with the letters I s and then
space and here we have is Facebook
downwards it's probably something people
search a lot when Facebook goes down but
the second most common question starting
with is asked to Google is is Lady Gaga
a man I'll just go ahead and answer that
one for everyone no no Lady Gaga is not
a man and then we have the beginning of
a trend that we will see a lot in Google
autocompletes is Daniel Tosh gay is
Justin Bieber gay is Nate Berkus gay I
don't even know who neat Perkis is but
to peer deeper into our nation's psyche
you could type in is my and find out
what people are curious about concerning
their possessions including is my
husband gay is my boyfriend gay is my
Mac 64-bit which is actually a
legitimate normal Google question why
aren't they all like that is my license
suspended which is a question you really
should know the answer to and is my
house haunted which I am amazed I am I
am just amazed and then go deeper just
type a random letter is my dick is my
dog pregnant is my dog sick is my dog
dying is my dog gay yes your dog is yeah
actually you know I was probably by
actually your dog is probably omnisexual
your dog has probably had sex with
pillows your dog is probably ejaculating
on the arm of a couch right now Wow our
hangups
we have them and then I had a bit of
inspiration and I had to go ahead and
type in is John Green and John I know
you want to know what the world wants to
know about you is John Green married yes
is John Green gay is John Green gay why
does everybody want to know if
everybody's gay let me just go ahead and
answer all these questions for you we
have yes no yes yes no John Green is not
bad so of course now that I know what
people want to know about you I had to
figure out what people want to know
about me and peace of a rooster
fartknocker mother of poo no one cares
about what Hank Green is good you go
Google is Hank green awesome maybe if
enough people do it
it will autocomplete I find this
exploration fascinating particularly
their obsession with the sexual
orientation of other people and I am
looking forward to delving deeper into
our nation's psyche using the tool of
Google autocomplete and of course
finally I had to ask Google what people
are asking about Google one letter into
it we're already asking if Google is
making us stupid but we're also asking
is God real and has gonorrhea curable
but go ahead and type in is Google gah
and you will find out that fewer people
are asking whether Google is gaining a
monopoly on the world's information and
are asking whether Google is gay John
Google is a genderless website that
hopefully has never had a thought
modulus a feeling of romantic longing
and thus we could all assume that Google
is not gay John I will see you on Monday
some various news I just had a collab
video with horrible fiction you can
click to watch it here the winners of
the project Ross and Ravel have been
announced and you have been contacted if
you want if you haven't been contacted
you you win it giving money to charity
thank you I hope you all have a very
very very very very very very very very
Happy New Year